what's happening reject nation i
am greg john do your best crosshairs
impression
i'm crosshairs very good that's what the
fans want we're going to watch
the bad batch episode 3 today
very excited to check it out if you
haven't done so already hit that like
button
subscribe click that notification bell
check us out on patreon
over there we got full length watch
alongs where you sync up with the time
code for the bad batch and we have
a whole bunch of other shows are at the
same tier you get the option for both
reaction highlights and
watch-alongs included it's a good deal
and john
why don't you thank our editor for this
one and your your best
uh any clone voice i'd like to thank for
a thumb gin
doll for editing this video that's
wrecker for you
sorry keon reeves
hit me again well that's all for now
rations are low
you can have mine hey megan doesn't even
have a place to sleep
you want to take a food too
yeah yeah definitely no no thanks you
keep it
oh you have a heart
echo lights cut out again i thought you
fixed it
yeah add it to the list the ship got hit
the shipwide diagnostic report indicated
no critical systems were compromised
the power capacitors we need to land
immediately
i love the kinship that's forming
between wrecker and omega
[Applause]
hold on
is it over survive your first roller
coaster kid
i know it's like that disneyland ride
greeting ct 9904
governor tarkin hope i'm not
interrupting right on schedule rampart
here's the guy with the chain codes yeah
what is the status of project war mantle
on schedule sir our top recruits are
here to begin their training
under their new commander
oh no yep yeah i betcha
ruling government requires an increase
in soldiers to maintain order throughout
the galaxy
oh they're building up to the storm
troopers
oh got it replacements
may i present our first elite squad
top soldiers from across the galaxy
partnerships such as this could have
promise
i believe it will strengthen the future
of this burgeoning empire
recruitment
a really great depth of field this is
like that
empire strikes back scene careful
those capacitors hold massive charge
when han was
you know talking about guys i just need
to secure it who's
hot
what was that i'm a little busy at the
moment why don't you go
check it out
at least whip your gun out man that
should do it
look at this
[Music]
well those weren't there when we landed
good observation
that's exactly why i brought you here
yes it does feel like aliens
oh damn it do you remember when the
xenomorph did that
yeah they'd love eating capacitors
now it's not the time to get home the
capacitors in place
but other systems are now failing
something's causing damage to the
exterior hull
you want to narrow that down
that's 100 just criticizes them
that's what a good leader does
what what is it
some kind of creature that ran off with
the part
kid now is no time for fantasies the
creature is most likely an auto moon
dragon
a species that feeds on raw energy it
was probably drawn to the capacitor's
electric charge
that would have been good to know
beforehand
[Laughter]
wrecker stay here i'll go after the
dragon and get our pot back going on
with his head
his inhibitor chip has to be acting up
or something no that thing could be
dangerous
i'm part of the squad now too right
all right kid just stay close
[Music]
yep stay close
conscripted recruits will never reach
the same level of military proficiency
our clones have been trained since their
creation
the loyalty of those who willingly
enlist is what i see tremendous value in
fair send the clone and your recruits to
underwrong
i want saugeras
let's see if they can succeed with clone
force 99.
no it's like i'm going to be out of a
job sorry
exactly facing you selling my clones
elsewhere
what else can we teach these things to
do
what are you doing dragging could i
learn to track like you
well it's an enhanced skill record tech
we
each have one and crosshair you
shouldn't be angry at him
he can't help it i'm angry at myself
we don't leave our own behind then we'll
find a way to get him back
[Music]
she's so hopeful
crosshair is gonna kill her this episode
yeah
[Laughter]
god no he's not why would they put him
in charge
problem if you all are so efficient
how come the empire scouting soldiers
like us sounds to me like it's time for
a change
enjoy being commander for now we'll see
how things shake out
oh crosstail kick his ass make an
example of him
is that one going to turn out to be
fenik shand sir
just receive the transmission from
guerrero all right let's move out
wait the sensor's been triggered in
sector 2a alert the others
get our people on the shuttle
see it wait here what's up
come on baby yoda levitate that thing
hunter wake up wake up
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
growing up fast you can do this
[Music]
oh
god this is a mess
oh
wow
where's guerrera i don't know but i
wouldn't tell you if i did
oh
that was so brutal cold
she's
those weren't our orders forget our
orders
ignore the clone we signed up to be
soldiers not an execution squad
you want to know why they put me in
charge
it's because i'm willing to do what
needs to be done
d-a-r-k i do enjoy watching cross hair
though you know
he's got screen time really cool to
watch got a lot of presents even under
that mask
oh duh
he give no shits anymore man not at all
well there it is
i guess i got lucky
give the dragon your flashlight
omega it's obiga omega
omega
[Applause]
just turn the lid off please thank you
exactly he wants energy
that's a great flashlight
i'm coming that's star wars wonder
are you okay what were you thinking
going down there the mission was to
retrieve the capacitor wasn't it
i tracked the dragon i was following
orders i got the part
guerrero was already gone but the rest
of his camp was
dealt with impressive the clone
commander's new squad has followed
through
where his brethren did not further proof
that this initiative has potential
then i leave this project in your
capable hands
admiral thank you sir
if rampart has his way conscripted
soldiers will make clones obsolete
i fear for the future of our operation
must ensure our clones remain essential
if your experiment can yield a superior
clone
it will secure our relationship with
this empire
indominus rex
people are bored with normal clones our
survival hinges on it
oh i kind of get the impression
crosshair misses them
i bet he does just a little bit
right little little tiny spark of
emotion in there
crazy little psychopath you kind of
missing
fight the chap he's compelling as hell
to watch
systems are up and running yeah i took
you long enough
i kid come with me
cover your eyes
[Music]
check it out
hmm did he make her a place to sleep
oh is it like a little makeshift bunk
[Music]
oh
wrecker builder builder
your new name constructor what do you
think
i thought this place could feel more
like a hoe ha
that's so sweet
[Music]
charge her rep yeah hold this over her
head always
you're part of this squad now too
oh awesome
great episode that was a really great
episode yeah
that was great i quite enjoyed that one
yeah it dawned on me
when watching this one how the same way
how i felt with clone wars
of when this show goes dark so i mean
two out of three
two out of three have been dark last one
not really that dark same thing with
clone wars whenever that show went dark
i
i weight preferred it and you know just
enhances a certain mature theme to it
just a little more quality it's more
tense and uh
i love how just like yeah it's a dark
episode
yet it felt still very
wholesome i would say like it still had
a very
like family quality especially the
dynamics whenever you cut back to
wrecker and omega or even just omega
looking out for hunter and
her learning how to solve a problem
without having to resort to using a
weapon that had this real wholesome
quality but then it also
still plays heavily into the menace that
is the
the overtaking of the empire and just
their growth that they are having i
appreciate that we're gonna actually
see the transition here from clones to
stormtroopers how we're
really gonna explore that and it's like
they're really setting that up with the
vice admiral rampart character who seems
like he's gonna be
one of the big baddies of this show like
we don't know star wars lore as well as
we ought to i know
so feel free to leave down your comments
below but vice i'm over rampart and him
talking about bringing in new people
that is the beginning process of
recruiting humans and then training them
did they state here why the clones are
getting weaker i didn't pick up on that
um the strand of django is not as strong
in terms of duplication
yeah i mean that element i took as being
sort of yeah we've been deriving all
these clones from
one genetic makeup all this time so it's
gotta be degrading or or dissipating or
something like that you know i
imagine you can't just produce infinite
clones of all the same quality there
and then two this idea that a
conscripted soldier somebody who really
cares to join your cause
is a more effective soldier overall i
thought was an interesting like
theoretical
counterweight to that you know you've
got the physical circumstance of like
okay now we got to kick into whatever
the next
phase is and create our next super clone
to physically secure
our agreement here but also you know the
empire is looking to find
soldiers who are really about that cause
and that's like the dark thing too
because now it's about conviction not
just about
numbers and just about orders you know i
think i'm trying to get a better sense
of what this show is setting out to
explore
in terms of like all these war themes
you're dealing with
the bad batch seems to be the the great
core of it
all especially to have crosshairs the
character who follows orders blindly
they don't even call him by his name
they call him by his number
these are people who don't really have
their own identity but yet they
they're able to they just conform
whereas the bad batch they have their
freedom
but you know if it's an even harder life
to live but you still get to form your
own identity
you know and then fighting for that and
and how in the end that's
more worth it how that's the better
cause like
really exploring that and it's like it
was pretty mature
tone themes to uh explore in this series
it's an animated show
you know it's following the clone wars
animation style it's got the family
friendly
animation touch however you know like
especially the way they did the violence
with
murdering the rebels over on onderon
like how they're
building up crosshair he just feels like
a full-on villain at this point
they go back to andron where they were
in the first episode where he went with
the group
like his people the bad batch and he
didn't agree with
the way how his leader hunter handled
not executing the people or following
through with orders
and he goes there and just the way he
wipes them out like he just don't he
just don't give two shits anymore
he's just doing what he has to do he
even kills one of the soldiers it's
compelling because
you're like man this this guy is evil
now he's ruthless
i actually would be kind of down for if
there was like a part of him that was
like even if without the chip he was
just a little bit messed up you know
what i mean
he's
yeah i don't think they're gonna do that
but but i feel like it would be an
interesting reveal
yeah absolutely and one thing i started
to hone in on or or
at least perhaps see unfolding in future
episodes this idea where
in the past couple the setup of the show
it seemed like oh damn we're gonna have
crosshairs on their tail this whole time
and it seems like that's going to be an
element but what i appreciate it here is
it seems like
the plan for crosshair appears bigger
than that it's not
just that oh the b plot's always gonna
be he's right behind
him trying to get him it's more they're
building his roll-up within this new
empire and that makes the debate that
much more difficult and also makes for a
lot more interesting character conflicts
i feel like with him
because yeah you get these little beats
like when they come back
after his new team puts up the same kind
of argument and the same fight against
his allegiance to the orders and it just
goes a completely different direction
because he's in charge
and so when he comes back and looks at
the wall and sees you know all their
notches that the bad batch made together
you can feel maybe that seed
settling in of like yeah this is
spiritually different in
some way that isn't the right way or
something
it's a compelling way to develop him
both as a character and as
the you know antagonist of this series
at least from a personal perspective you
know
absolutely i mean you start off the
episode with wrecker and them saying
like yeah we we have to we can't lie to
ourselves we miss crosshair
and even uh when omega and hunter are
out together looking for the
energy thingamajig how capacitor
bringing up crosshair seems triggering
the hunter like he doesn't even want to
acknowledge that she just brought him up
like when they're talking about their
special powers or the special
enhancements that they have and then you
end it with crosshair
doing like something very evil yet it
has this moment where
it seems like he he does have a he does
sort of miss them because they were
his family essentially and i love that
this feels very layered
it's very nuanced uh which is something
that
this show needs to keep doing in order
to stay uh
relevant for the star wars community it
needs to stay gripping and i feel like
more people will eventually
start latching on to this series with
better word of mouth as he keeps going
yeah absolutely and i like how they're
building up omega never really done too
much yet
there's like these little things here
and there that seem to
possibly indicate some force sensitivity
even with getting like that thing that
belonged to crosshair at the beginning
of this episode it was probably just a
coincidental moment but there's
something also there about the way how
she got it or dealing with the monster
at the end and the the dragon their
moments were like okay she could just be
really clever and she's figuring it out
you know but i'm trying
i guess you're just trying to figure out
like what's her special ability
everyone's got this enhancement what's
her enhancement
yeah is it that she they made her force
sensitive when the the people from
camino were talking at the end about
we need to get them back so we can make
better clones if they're talking about
getting the bad batch back that
we just need one do they need just one
of them are they trying to get omega
back so they can duplicate her
you know what is it about her that they
haven't but i appreciate that we're not
going too much into that yet about what
our enhancements are we're just focusing
on her character and her relationship
and how that's growing with the the rest
of the team and really making her feel
part of the family so
eventually when she is stripped away
from them in some dramatic tension and
stakes it'll feel like
no
overall i think to you this way because
yeah i like that you know i mean in the
first couple episodes it does sort of
feel like oh yeah we got this plucky kid
along with us and she's gung-ho about
everything but especially here by
episode three the rapport that's
building between her and the crew and
yeah the way in which they're tapping
into in such a dark episode in a lot of
respects
the more wondrous and the more sort of
awestruck potential of the universe you
know is sort of embodied through her in
this episode
so i like that they're able to still
keep those tones touched upon and then
those
almost then to me at least sort of
bolster what i know is coming at least
in terms of there's going to be some big
reveal about what her
special trait is or her special ability
or whatever and yeah i like that
they're not seemingly rushing just to
get to that it seems like they're
really taking time to do the character
route instead of the we need this cool
element route
yeah we're only episode three and
there's a lot of there's more episodes
here than you would get in like man like
the episodes are shorter but you're
gonna get more episodes than you would
get in a season of mandalorian oh yeah
so i think in terms of character
development and building that up you
could feel how there's like these little
enhancements in terms of growth
before the relationships world building
plot every single episode like they're
not
pushing or rushing through it so yeah
i'm like only episode three in and
so far two out of three i've loved like
i liked the last one but the
but the first and this one i really love
i loved quite a bit so yeah man
episode damn good episode and some great
atmospheres some great just
textures and visual aura like yeah and i
really like the dynamic between uh the
chemistry of
tech and echo their tension just seems
to be building up more and more and more
and more
they're just gonna throw down fists one
day they're a great yeah odd couple
right now yeah especially and also to
appreciate you know like how you brought
up alien they did
like play into some like real menacing
horror tones throughout too
which is always a nice nice addition for
folks like us yeah you get your
atmospheric horror and then you get your
character-centric horror
yeah exactly and the horror of following
orders
which is like a huge theme across the
star wars galaxies
don't don't just follow those orders
sometimes you question
even the even the new storm trooper
recruits had the sense to be like this
doesn't seem right
yeah yeah well i mean yeah you're
you're gonna see how they learn to
really condition humans
but i believe my memory might be off
here
i think they'd establish in the original
trilogy that they get them when they're
kids still
and then
you're way off man you have no idea how
bad they're gonna be at shooting
could not help but think the irony that
they paired this group of recruits with
the the marksmen of the bad bad the guy
with the best dame
is training what will soon become the
force with the worst name
crosshair do your job we'll see maybe
maybe it won't play out that way
yeah it's true it won't play out that
way maybe he'll train them to aim too
because this episode still ended on it
looks like the clones are more viable
right now like we know it's not going to
be
the case eventually there won't be
clones but right now at this point in
time we don't know what the how it's
going to progress
yeah they're safe for now yeah all i
know is those
camino people are going to be looking
into getting a sba government
yeah it's going to take a while because
they don't talk very fast
they get that ppp loan prove they paid
their taxes and that they're
self-employed
oh yeah yeah yeah you got all their
write-offs
any tax breaks they can get all right
guys
well the bad batch episode three
replacements what did you think about
this did you know john favreau who
directed
uh you know the mandalorian show
is also one of the stars of the movie
the replacements
oh wow this is the aggressive tackler
dude
john favreau yeah it all ties in
wow the fab view to the fav reverse
that's what this is restore the fab
rovers
to the real rejects leave your thoughts
down below like the buttons click the
bells do whatever you got to do to keep
your [ __ ] together
last but not least hey let's give a pic
colin anderson colin undoubtably
undoubtedly this is without a doubt
undoubtedly there's one thing i cannot
doubt undoubtedly undoubtedly cannot
doubt the doubt
it's undoubtedly undoubtable is that
colin anderson
travels more than everyone else at our
patreon page
certainly he takes more trips in a year
visits more beautiful
naturistic landscapes in a year than
john and i do within a decade and you
know what if there's one person
at our patreon you know where i'm going
with this who has the capability of one
day
making it to space travel oh
fat you're the fast and the furious it's
him you're gonna do it colin
i could see you being the kind of guy
who's like let me hit up that elon musk
so that way i could go into space x
experience it all i know you dude
i know you you would love to do that
bring some moon rocks back
you could have star wars space
adventures man
i can see you doing it make the kessel
run do it do it you're a good guy colin
i hate when you send me instagram pics
because i'm like
oh it's cool you're living the life i
want that's awesome thanks for reminding
me
you're doing stuff i don't do
i don't even ask you and you just send
me stuff
but i appreciate you being part of our
patreon absolutely
[Music]